hey this might come as a surprise to you
this might sound shocking but North
Korea appears to be upgrading a nuclear
research facility according to new
satellite imagery now I want to remind
you that Donald Trump claimed victory
last month after his Singapore summit
with Kim jong-un he came out of it
saying we did it it is a major win
I trust the guy he has a great sense of
humor he's a great negotiator he's
extraordinarily smart and it seems that
the one true thing that Donald Trump
said about Kim jong-un is that he is a
great negotiator because he was able to
negotiate all sorts of commitments from
Donald Trump without actually doing
anything towards denuclearization and
we've now learned through new satellite
images that not only has North Korean
denuclearization not started they are
actually expanding their nuclear
research capabilities or at minimum not
dismantling them and North Korea
analysis done by outlet third by the
media outlet 38 North is reporting that
over the last month North Korea has been
making a number of significant
improvements to a nuclear research
facility new cooling water pump house
new buildings a new cooling water
reservoir a radiochemical lab that seems
to be active if you're preparing to
denuclearize you usually don't start
doing major upgrades to your nuclear
research facility now let me make a
counter point because there is a counter
point to be made here the counter point
would be the negotiation happened two
weeks ago and all we know is that this
progress in North Korea has taken place
in the last month meaning it's possible
that the upgrades took place four and
three weeks ago and then did stop after
Donald Trump's summit with North Korea
well it's possible but what's clear at
this point is that no denuclearization
has started which is exactly what Donald
Trump claimed this week was going on
Donald Trump saying they're way ahead
they are moving full speed ahead on
denuclearization clearly they are not
Jim mattis our Secretary of Defense said
that they are not and now satellite
images confirmed that they are not
denuclearizing who could have predicted
path that denuclearization deals with
rogue nation
could be a difficult thing to manage
completely unpredictable right yeah I
wonder what's gonna happen now or the
joint military exercises between the
u.s. and South Korea going to start up
again or the little rocket man tweets
gonna come back are we going to escalate
this situation and make it worse than it
ever was
how dare North Korea for the 15th time
not denuclearize after they said they
were going to denuclearize how does that
old phrase go fool me 15 times
shame on you fool me a sixteenth time
you can't get fooled again is really the
main thing that we come away with I
believe that this entire North Korea
thing is actually a distraction from the
Canadian strategic maple syrup reserve I
believe that that's really where our
national security focus should be and
this entire North Korea thing is just a
farce okay let's play devil's advocate
here Kim jong-un gets back he has every
intention of denuclearizing but he's
busy with his concubines and public
humiliation and assassination of people
and he just hasn't gotten around to
telling the nuclear research team that
they're denuclearizing but he still has
every intention to denuclearize is that
at all possible yeah I mean maybe his
priorities just aren't in the right
order I think who could have seen this
like that who could have seen this woman
we're completely blindsided by this it's
absolutely and utterly shocking Donald
Trump was the negotiator in chief wrote
the art of the deal I wouldn't expect
that from him yeah like I said I
wouldn't bring this guy to negotiate my
next car lease never mind
national international geopolitical
denuclearization send me your thoughts
if I'm being overly harsh on Trump here
and there there's some explanation as to
why everything's fine and we should
completely I can't even say it with a
straight face if we should completely
trust the promises of Kim jong-un
despite all evidence tell me tell me and
then I will come back to the audience
and say here is the best case that
someone in our audience was able to make
about why Kim jong-un can be trusted
join the subreddit at david pakman.com
slash re d di t quick break back after
this today's program is made possible in
part by
fruit or boot or is a social
or casting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board from politics to
sports and everything in between
you wager on predictions about real
world events using futures in-game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
and improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account
and follow me by clicking the link in
the description if you're watching this
on YouTube
this week on futur I pose the question
will there be a congressional hearing
regarding the Trump sexual assault
allegations what do you think click the
link in the description and place your
bets and you can browse the politics
category on futur to wager on other
predictions sign up now at futurecom and
start making your forecasts on political
topics and tons of other topics totally
free available on both Android and iOS
and right now on foote or you can win
cash prizes for correct predictions
about the World Cup check it out at fut
you you are calm